Well,
it's been
two ways that the,
that this economic expansion,
it's subsidized by the environment,
one is just the sort of non market
consequences,
most notably say greenhouse gas
pollution at the all of us who use that
pollution,
but those who sell it to us,
particularly your responsible for a huge
environmental impact that they are not
paying for a,
but they're also,
that problem is compounded by the
addition of subsidies by governments.
And there's one estimate that the
environmentally perverse subsidies
internationally now amount to perhaps a
eight,
at least $800,000,000,000 a year.
And a,
this is an energy.
It's an agriculture and transportation
and that further distorts the price
mechanism.
And as a result,
we have these environmentally dishonest
prices.
This basic system then is compounded by
three other things.
Uh,
first is an enormous,
um,
is the way that corporations are set up.
We've now charter corporations and
established corporate law,
uh,
that says in effect,
the overwhelming duty of the corporation
is to maximize the wealth of the
shareholders.
This is the so called shareholder
primacy,
best interest of the corporation
principle.
Uh,
it's totally outmoded and in my view,
I mean we ought to be exploring
rigorously a system where the
corporation is governed by and beholding
to all of those that contribute to the
wealth that the shareholder,
that the cooperation produces.
And that would include local
communities,
it would include workers,
uh,
so it's a fundamental change in the way
that corporations are set up and the
incentives that they operate under.
The second pillar of this is less,
uh,
is our,
our pathetic capitulation to
consumerism.
Uh,
and that's,
of course it's manipulated endlessly by
advertisers and,
and marketing and we succumb easily,
uh,
and,
and off we go,
uh,
and that is certainly a huge pillar of
the system.
The,
the third,
a is government itself.
The state,
the state can raise extra revenues
without raising tax rates by growing a,
it can keep social issues on the back
burner by pointing to the expansion of
the economy as a solution to social,
uh,
growth enhances the projection of power,
in international,
in a competitive international system.
So governments that are deeply hooked on
growth.
So this is the basic complex and it's
enormously powerful.
And the environmental community,
um,
this is simply a unable to cope with the
full burden of that system.
Well
already clear that if we had a world
that had environmentally honest prices
and indeed socially honest prices and
militarily honest prices,
prices would be a lot higher,
a lot higher,
both in general.
So the reaction of people would be to
shift good,
shift their activities out of the
market,
which in many ways is a wonderful thing
because it means we would be spending
more time with our families,
more time with our communities,
more time with the natural world.
And it would also mean the activities
that are environmentally destructive
would cost a lot more,
a lot more.
Uh,
and the effect of this is to,
um,
you know,
shift our consumer patterns towards
things that are environmentally
regenerative or benign.
Um,
but they're huge equity issues here.
Uh,
we,
um,
and that's why in the book I really,
go approach in several ways,
the link between dealing with our
environmental issues and dealing with
the social justice issues in our
country.
Um,
we have a crisis of social inequality in
America as well as an environmental
crisis,
a soaring executive pay a and earnings
in is the top one percent of the
country,
um,
and a widening gap between the very rich
and the rest of the country.
Poverty rates at an all time high,
uh,
over 10 percent of the public facing
hunger still in our country,
if you can believe that,
uh,
in a one percent of the adult population
in jail,
a failing schools,
uh,
unprecedented proportion of the society
with a out health insurance,
uh,
and,
and just tremendous social insecurity
among most people in the country.
Half the families in the country make
less than about $45,000 a year.
The family,
it could be pretty big and they and,
and the average of that half is well
below 45 of course.
So basically,
you know,
we have a society with tremendous wealth
and tremendous capacity,
but it's very concentrated and it spent
on.
It's not spent on promoting social
wellbeing in our society.
So,
and,
and the environmental pictures,
no prettier.
So what we really have is a system that
cares profoundly about profits and
reinvesting a large share of them and
growing.
He doesn't really care much at all about
people society or the natural world in
which it's embedded.
And that's why it's up to us as citizens
to use the main tool that we have,
which is government,
uh,
to inject a real values,
other values,
human values,
longterm values,
caring values,
compassionate values,
natural values into the system.
And,
and that's where we fail too often and
failed in a big way because our politics
are so enfeebled today,
uh,
and the corporate control of our
politics is,
is so strong,
uh,
that were failing.
And,
but the point is that we're all
similarly situated,
those who are trying to succeed in,
in,
in projecting values for about future
generations and about the natural world
into that system are failing just for
the same reasons that those who are
trying to project into that system or
inject into that system values about
social justice and social wellbeing and
social cohesion,
uh,
in our country and the same.
And so we all have,
uh,
we're,
communities of shared fate,
and yet we're not talking to each other.